people really coming for that romp huh
coming for The Romp I'm like I've been
in Nashville for 12 years trying to do
music and here we are the butt goes
viral and I mean they they find the
music through the butt and they plan on
sticking around but
it's uh yeah I'm trying to embrace it
yeah nothing will keep a man around like
some bud I think that's right that's
right I'm like whatever whatever makes
them listen to the music yeah hey look
sometimes they start with the bass
section you know before they get to the
trouble you know that's yeah that's
exactly it I think that's all it is I
think that's all it is too I mean I
didn't know how to feel about it in the
beginning I was like
I thought it was going to be just this
little little tiny viral thing and next
thing I know weeks later I'm still
seeing
big old butts I just remember seeing
that it was like um
some yeah it was like a side angle if
you want to stage and and then with the
leopard pants yeah now that'll probably
do it's like an optical illusion I don't
think my butt's really that big I think
it was the leopard I mean maybe the
leopard had a big butt oh my God that is
see wow that was that was a good day
also this is a wide screen let's be
honest I mean look I'm just saying y'all
doing me dirty this is 16.9 baby I think
whatever that is
you got that Silver Screen rear dang
that thing is uh it's out there yeah
that cheetah must have been strong
what's what's weird is people like
where'd you get that from and I say I
get the the width from my mama and the
depth from my Daddy really my Daddy's
got a he got a little booty on it does
he yeah yeah
the girl actually and she had her
father's butt I love your voice thank
you yeah that's really nice thank you
very much um it's a gift I feel like to
the whole world I'm sure a lot of people
feel that way I feel like when you're
singing like somebody's singing from
like
I feel like somebody's singing from the
past I mean I feel like it's probably
from like yeah I just feel like they're
it's like coming from another
I'll take that thank you like plain or
something I'm like it's almost like
sometimes I feel like I was born in the
wrong decade really yeah I mean who
knows what I was doing in a in a
previous life but I yeah I've kind of
have some weird feelings like that too
so yeah yeah like do you think of a time
like do you feel like there's a time
like
do you get a sense of what is going on
around you at that time if it was a past
I mean
I don't know what it was
um
but I do feel I do feel like a little
bit of an old soul
I don't know I don't know if it's which
I have some family members and stuff who
I think kind of feel the same way so
maybe it's just something like a little
thing kind of passed down but yeah I
wonder who I was who was that yeah yeah
where are you who were you oh I know who
you could have been you could have been
like a trained conductor but before they
had a whistle so you had to also be the
whistle so you had to be like uh-huh
like you had to really belt it out you
know I'm just trying to think of
something where you'd also have to be
like real verbose and like let them know
you know
yeah
and what if he would have come or what
if somebody else was a conductor and you
just were you were the horn like they
didn't no I was a caboose don't even
play I was I was the Caboose I have seen
some videos on Tick Tock
I'm gonna give me some horses can you be
on a horse easily oh yeah oh really oh
yeah I definitely I mean we rodeoed a
little bit me and my sister we were PRCA
Rodeo flag girls oh what is it that big
old bullet State isn't a saddle you know
what I'm talking about really
not is your sister pretty cheap though
it ain't as far out but it's definitely
as far this way okay okay yeah yeah yeah
so she ain't going nowhere in the saddle
either
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one